all across ecosystems we know that
organisms interact in specific ways and
scientists use special words to describe
these types of interaction
competition predation and mutualism so
let's first talk about competition which
we have already talked about in other
videos in this picture here do you see
competition pause this video and think
about that
well one limited resource that these
animals need to survive is water there's
only a limited amount in this watering
hole over here and so you can imagine
there is competition not just amongst
the members of a population let's say
between the zebra but also between
members of different species between
different populations in a community the
zebras are not just competing for water
with each other but also with these
antelope or with these buffalo over here
there might also be competition for food
it doesn't seem like there's a lot of
grass to eat for all of these animals
that like to graze on grass
so now let's move on to predation
predation is when one organism eats
another organism usually to its own
benefit do you see any predation
happening here well we don't see any of
these animals chasing and killing each
other there might be other animals like
lions off-screen that might hunt and
kill and eat these animals right over
here but we know that these animals do
eat grass and as i said it's not just
about hunting and killing and eating
from one animal to another it could be
one organism to another so the eating of
the grass by these animals could
actually be considered a form of
predation especially if it kills the
grass
a more obvious form of predation is this
brown bear here that has
gotten the salmon out of this river it
is clearly hunting and killing the
salmon for its benefit and it is likely
that each of these bears are in
competition with other bears for this
limited resource
so last but not least let's think a
little bit about mutualism mutualism
happens when two organisms benefit from
interacting with each other
right over here we have these starlings
that actually hang out on this buffalo
and pick lice and ticks off the
buffalo's fur this is mutualism because
both parties benefit the starlings are
able to get food and the buffalo no
longer have these parasites these things
that are living off of the buffalo
sucking its blood out of its body and
also probably not itching as much
now based on how i just described it
there's not just mutualism here there's
also a predation because these birds are
actually hunting and killing the lice
and the ticks on the buffalo's body now
related to being a predator is another
word known as being a parasite and
that's what the lice and the ticks are
doing where they're sucking the blood of
the buffalo but they're not considered
predators they're more parasites because
they don't kill the buffalo they're just
taking some resources away from it
so i'll leave you there i encourage you
when you look at nature when you go to a
park next time when you go watch a
documentary i encourage you to think
about how competition predation and
mutualism is happening in an ecosystem
that you are seeing or that you're a
part of